[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a este nuevo episodio
de boleto de vuelta soy raúl blanco hoy
por mi compañera paula jiménez vamos a
ir hasta mina mata una ciudad portuaria
en el sureste de japón que hace 60 años
fue noticia por la enfermedad de
minamata una grave intoxicación por
mercurio durante los años 50 los médicos
prendieron las alarmas los primeros
afectados fueron los animales gatos que
daban vueltas convulsionaban y luego
morían poco a poco otras especies
también vieron afectadas se vieron
afectadas rápidamente y aparecieron los
primeros casos en humanos pérdida del
habla de la vista y el oído movimientos
desordenados convulsiones y muertes que
se multiplicaron las familias de los
pescadores fueron las más afectadas los
investigadores encontraron que la
contaminación provenía de los pescados
cuya carne estaba plagada de mercurio
pero se necesitaron varios meses antes
de dar que una clave una fábrica química
la de hechizo que desde
1951 vertía en la bahía un derivado del
mercurio y sin embargo la fábrica siguió
produciendo y contaminando las aguas
hasta 1968 cuando las autoridades
reconocieron la responsabilidad de la
compañía se estima que la contaminación
es causa de más de 1.500 muertes
importantes discapacidades y graves
malformaciones congénitas en la
población de minamata hoy miles de
habitantes esperan ser reconocidos como
víctimas además de una indemnización por
parte del gobierno veamos este boleto de
vuelta
sin sabor ni color pero letal
durante décadas el mercurio permaneció
oculto en estas piscinas aguas y en los
peces que los locales pesca van y luego
consumían esta fue la causa de una
enfermedad tan destructiva que se volvió
sinónimo de una ciudad entera minamata
hoy es un día importante para los 25.000
habitantes de minamata ubicada en la
costa suroccidental de japón
una película sobre uno de los peores
casos de contaminación industrial de los
tiempos modernos está a punto de ser
proyecta aquí por primera vez en el país
la estrella de la película johnny depp
le envía un mensaje a los residentes de
minamata
es un gran honor para mí invitarlos a
ver nuestra nueva película me la mata en
la cual estoy muy orgulloso de haber
participado
espero que los inspira dos emociones y
los con nuevas
gracias
la película trata sobre la historia real
del fotoperiodista estadounidense eugene
smith y su esposa elin 2000 quienes
llegaron a minamata en 1971 determinados
a contarle al mundo la tragedia que
estaba ocurriendo aquí
eugen murió en
aylín que tenía poco más de 20 años
cuando empezaron a trabajar juntos ahora
es un activista ambiental en japón
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el yin y yang edad se parecen tanto que
durante un momento pensé que estaba
yendo de nuevo a mi esposo cuando johnny
depp dijo que no sólo produciría la
película sino que actuaría en ella me
emocioné y me preocupé al mismo tiempo
es algo que yo experimenté y sé lo
importante que fue este suceso para
todas las personas en la audiencia todos
los habitantes de minamata pueden estar
orgullosos de la película
alrededor de 1000 personas vinieron a
ver la proyección especial éxito en las
taquillas entre el público hay víctimas
de la enfermedad de minamata y antiguos
trabajadores de hechizo la empresa
química causante de la contaminación
aún no he cumplido 20 años pero siente
que la contaminación es un problema
serio
las personas jóvenes deben conocer esta
historia
me gustaría que a través de esta
película todo el mundo comprenda los
peligros de la contaminación
nunca deberíamos volver a cometer este
tipo de error
aylín ha dedicado gran parte de su vida
a la causa de minamata
fue en esta bahía a unos cuantos
kilómetros del centro de la ciudad donde
se diagnóstico el primer caso en mayo de
y chau
un niño se enfermó gravemente muchas
personas de estas zonas se enfermaron
los niños eran vecinos así que había una
gran preocupación sobre la posibilidad
de que fuera contagioso
a las personas afectadas se les
dificultaba mucho hablar sus miembros se
desfiguraron algunos perdieron la vista
y el oído sin embargo durante años nadie
hizo la conexión entre sus síntomas y la
comida contaminada con mercurio
después suspiro formando
el lugar era muy hermoso los mariscos
eran muy frescos y sabían muy bien
no hubo cambios en el sabor incluso
después de que la bahía se contaminará
nadie habría imaginado que contenían
veneno
en esa época se le recomendaba a las
mujeres embarazadas que comieran pescado
rico en proteínas no sabían que estaban
envenenando a sus hijos nonatos
buenos días
esta mujer se enfermó estando aún en el
vientre de su madre 65 años atrás
esperemos que nos siga subiendo la
temperatura hace mucho calor aylín le
hizo muchas fotografías así nose
sakamoto y ambas mujeres se volvieron
buenas amigas hace ocho años sakamoto
todavía podía caminar y viajó por el
mundo para advertir sobre los peligros
de la contaminación por mercurio de las
3.000 personas que han sido oficialmente
reconocidas como víctimas ella es una de
las pocas que siguen vivas
un día mientras me preparaba para ir a
la escuela
escucha mi madre hablar sobre mi
enfermedad con los vecinos
[Música]
así fue como descubrí que estaba enferma
y
me sentía muy triste aunque esperaba
poder recuperarme
no hay cura para la enfermedad de
minamata a pesar del dolor físico con el
que vive sakamoto está activa y
mentalmente alerta
y
realmente tienes muy buen sentido del
humor no
siempre estás de buen ánimo
los científicos no identificaron el
envenenamiento por mercurio como la
causa de la enfermedad hasta 1959 se
encontraron altas concentraciones de la
sustancia en las aguas cerca de la
fábrica química y fertilizante de
hechizo o
sarean los pacientes desesperados se
sentaban justo aquí de share en en fan
the company y se sentaban en frente de
la empresa y le pedían ayuda from the
company hizo le ofreció a las víctimas
mi making un tipo de indemnización
extraoficial siempre y cuando retiraran
su demanda muchos aceptaron el dinero
por pura desesperación aún así la
empresa siguió contaminando la bahía
durante otra década provocando una nueva
demanda en
1969 la gerencia de la fábrica destruyó
la evidencia pero el caso tomó un giro
dramático después de un testimonio
crucial y de una intervención felina en
saint germain the factory detectará que
esperar más
fue aquí adentro de la fábrica donde el
doctor jose agua llevaba a cabo
experimentos con los datos él era el
director del hospital de la fábrica de
cheese o
alimentaba a los gatos con varios
contaminantes de la fábrica cuando les
daba mercurio los síntomas que los gatos
presentaban eran idénticos a la
enfermedad de minamata la empresa le
ordenó que dejara de realizar los
experimentos con los gatos como dirigía
el hospital de la fábrica y trabajaba
para hachís o se mantuvo en silencio
pero al final cuando estaba muriendo de
cáncer decidió testificar
chizo recibió la orden de pagar
alrededor de 60 mil euros a cada uno de
los 138 demandantes pero el daño ya
estaba hecho no sólo a las víctimas sino
a la reputación de minamata
y muchas personas quieren ocultar que
son de minamata cuando van afuera a las
grandes ciudades
[Música]
incluso ahora si uno lleva algo y dice
que fue cultivado en minamata un
producto desarrollado en minamata o una
fruta por ejemplo tiene la etiqueta de
minamata y eso es lo que le entristece a
las personas y a lo que se oponen las
farc y por richard burns ya hizo cambió
su nombre y su negocio pero sigue
ubicada en minamata la compañía se negó
a contestar a las preguntas de france 24
alrededor de 20.000 personas aún están
involucradas en una batalla legal para
ser reconocidas como víctimas oficiales
entre ellas está y desató sus padres que
se ganaron la vida en el negocio de la
pesca enfermaron y murieron tras ser
oficialmente reconocidos como víctimas
de minamata y de aquí que sufre de
ataques de vértigo todos los días es un
pescador apasionado pero se mantiene
alejado del área donde sus padres solían
pescar
había es posible encontrar mercurio en
el lodo de estas aguas las autoridades
locales afirman que el mar a las afueras
de minamata está libre de toda
contaminación pero a causa de las
décadas de mentiras muchos locales no
les creen
honestamente tengo dudas estoy bastante
preocupado este lugar debería estar bien
pero nunca se puede estar seguro de que
hayan eliminado todo el mercurio solo en
los lugares donde había una alta
concentración
pero no quiero hablar de eso porque no
quiero preocupar a las personas
si eso pasa dejarán de comprar pescado
local
sato y su mujer interpusieron una
demanda contra chicó en 2007 buscando
ser reconocidos como víctimas y obtener
una indemnización
me empezaron a doler mucho las piernas
cuando tenía 2 o 3 años
lloraba todos los días
yo sé
en la escuela casi no podía estar de pie
todo el tiempo me sentía mareado y
sufría de tinnitus nunca se me ha
quitado
a la pareja le han pedido algo imposible
demostrar que consumieron pescado
contaminado de minamata hace 60 años
estas son algunas de las preguntas que
me hizo el juez de radio
ay señor sato usted pesca no es así yo
contesté sí
usted maneja una lancha yo contesté si
yo pesco navego puedo manejar las olas y
el oleaje me contestaron que era extraño
que pudiera hacer todas esas cosas que
si era una verdadera víctima de la
enfermedad de minamata no podría ser
capaz de hacerlas
mina mata ha perdido dos tercios de sus
pescadores desde 1960 muchos de ellos
murieron por la enfermedad otros
cambiaron de actividad y se dedicaron al
cultivo de frutas oa la producción de té
y dx su mujer su emmy ahora siembran
fruta orgánica tan solo pensar en
utilizar químicos les produce horror
utilizar pesticidas sería cometer los
mismos errores que cometió chicos
pero nosotros no queremos vender fruta
envenenada así que aquí todo es orgánico
mira matas
un día volveremos a sentirnos orgullosos
de haber nacido aquí en minamata
[Música]
este parque ecológico fue diseñado para
reparar la afectada reputación de
minamata construido sobre terrenos
recuperados cerca de la costa se
encuentra encima de depósitos sellados
de mercurio hoy en día las personas
traen aquí a sus hijos para jugar y
disfrutar del espacio verde
el parque se ve hermoso
está muy bien aquí traemos a nuestra
hija y cuando crezca podrá correr por
este lugar
definitivamente volveremos y nos
divertiremos
porque se construyó este parque sí lo
sabemos conocemos toda la historia pero
no estoy segura de que los jóvenes
recetan
el administrador del parque y origen a
edad piensa que la contaminación por
mercurio no es más que un mal recuerdo
se sacó todo el lodo contaminado con una
gran bomba y se puso aquí luego se
filtró el agua dejando que el lodo se
secará y se solidificará añadimos un
metro de arena y tres metros de tierra
encima del lodo y lo cubrimos todo ahora
todo el área de la bahía de minamata que
estaba contaminada está cubierta
a algunos residentes les preocupa que un
fuerte terremoto o un tsunami pueda
sacar a la superficie el lodo
contaminado destruyendo el parque y
causando fugas de mercurio en el agua
estos jóvenes no parecen tener las
mismas preocupaciones
ahora minamata es conocido como un buen
lugar para observar caballitos de mar un
símbolo de esperanza y recuperación
no no
[Música]
eso es música para los oídos de maeda en
cuanto al pescado local insiste en que
es perfectamente seguro consumirlo
los jóvenes de minamata no les preocupa
la enfermedad
somos realmente afortunados
es un gran lugar para criar niños o
desgracia te basta muchos famosos han
visitado el lugar y consumido los
productos locales de mar por televisión
son cuidadosos al no decir que sabe bien
a pesar de provenir de minamata sino que
sabe bien por qué proviene de minamata
ya mí me encanta escuchar eso
[Música]
pero para las personas que viven con la
enfermedad y buscan ser oficialmente
reconocidas como víctimas el proceso de
recuperación aún está por comenzar
recuerde que se le gustó este reportaje
puede verlo nuevamente a través de
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hace una próxima oportunidad
[Música]